[Música]
una semana tan solo una semana es el
tiempo que ha necesitado este hombre el
nuevo presidente de eeuu para tener su
primera gran crisis diplomática con
quien por supuesto lo sabéis con méxico
donald trump es único tal vez sólo él
sea capaz de retar públicamente a un
presidente extranjero en este caso a
peña nieto diciéndole por twitter que si
no va a washington con la idea de pagar
el muro mejor que se quede en casa por
supuesto la visita nunca se produjo
he dicho una y otra vez méxico no pagar
ánimo pero tranquilos porque donald no
va a ser el protagonista al menos
principal de este vídeo hace un tiempo
hicimos este otro vídeo sobre ver nada
que podría ser la política
proteccionista de trama entonces muchos
de vosotros nos pedisteis que hablásemos
del nafta del tratado de libre comercio
de norteamérica
y eso es precisamente lo que vamos a
hacer hoy en este vídeo prestado por
supuesto especial atención a la relación
de méxico con eeuu
el nafta el nafta el inglés o el té le
caen en castellano es un acuerdo de
libre comercio entre eeuu canadá y
méxico fue negociado y firmado por el
presidente george bush padre en 1992 y
ratificado e implantado por bill clinton
en el 94
es decir el nafta ha sido apoyado en
eeuu tanto por demócratas como por
republicanos pero haciendo un poco de
historia prestemos atención a cuáles han
sido los acontecimientos en el lado sur
del río bravo viajemos hasta mediados de
la década de los 80 en aquel momento
méxico estaba agotado su modelo era el
de una economía cerrada y la verdad ya
no daba más de sí la situación de crisis
era casi continua de hecho fue en ese
preciso momento cuando comenzó realmente
la emigración masiva a eeuu y ojo no
hablamos de cualquier cosa sino de una
de las mayores olas migratorias de todos
los tiempos
ah
y eso a pesar de que por aquel entonces
los gringos no querían precisamente bien
en méxico desde que la guerra con eeuu
entre 1846 y 1848 méxico perdiese más de
la mitad de su territorio el sentimiento
popular en este país veía a eeuu como al
gran villano a gran enemigo pero el caso
es que en 1988 cuando estaba claro que
el modelo había fracasado el entonces
presidente de méxico carlos salinas que
por cierto se había formado en harvard
decidió dar carpetazo al modelo y
apostar por abrirse al mundo en sus
propias palabras eeuu no es la mayor
amenaza sino la mayor oportunidad y
desde luego los líderes estadounidenses
no perdieron la oportunidad se pusieron
manos a la obra y decidieron apostar por
extender a mexico el acuerdo de libre
comercio que recientemente habían
firmado con canadá así surgió el tlcan o
el nafta desde entonces las relaciones
entre eeuu y méxico se han multiplicado
casi exponencialmente hoy estas
relaciones entre ambos países superan
ampliamente los kings
2000 millones de dólares esto es una
cifra altísima para que os hagáis una
idea por cada minuto que pasa más de un
millón de dólares en productos atraviesa
la frontera entre eeuu y méxico
[Música]
es decir solo el tráfico comercial entre
eeuu y méxico
equivale a dos veces toda la economía de
chile y es mayor que la propia economía
de argentina pues bien el actual
inquilino en la casa blanca donald trump
amenaza incluso con tumbar este tratado
porque según dice es el peor acuerdo
para los intereses de eeuu jamás firmado
sánchez esto claro es lo que él dice la
realidad es un poco diferente podemos
decir que el nafta ha sido en general
una mina de oro para los eeuu
implicaciones del nazca y méxico para
eeuu dicen por ahí que cuando donald
trump tiene una pesadilla ve a un
mexicano robándole la cartera ese es mi
compromiso y tú sabes que lo voy a
cumplir en fin yo no sé si esto será
verdad pero desde luego esta historia
explicaría por que donald tiene tanta
obsesión con méxico y también porque
cada vez que escucha la palabra nafta su
cerebro se agita y grita robo robo pero
ojo no os penséis que es el único que
piensa así muchos defensores del
proteccionismo en eeuu afirman que los
trabajadores mexicanos y canadienses les
hacen perder cada año a su país miles de
millones de dólares por culpa del libre
comercio
en concreto dicen que las importaciones
superan cada año las exportaciones en
casi 80.000 millones que se dice pronto
[Música]
el problema amigos es que esta cifra
tiene más agujeros que un queso gruyère
en primer lugar hay dos productos que
distorsionan todos los datos y que no
tienen nada que ver con el nafta el
petróleo y el gas natural ojo porque si
excluimos estos productos ese agujero
comercial que denuncia trump desaparece
casi por completo vale tal vez alguno de
vosotros esté pensando en este momento
pero enrique porque no quieres tener en
cuenta el petróleo y el gas natural pues
porque es algo que donald trump quiera
devolver a eeuu a la edad de piedra digo
yo que este país tendrá que seguir
comprando todo el petróleo que necesita
ya sea canadá a méxico arabia saudita oa
la conchinchina
[Música]
y una y más porque aquí no termina el
juego de magia de estos ilusionistas del
proteccionismo aún queda otra trampa el
dato comercial del déficit que presentan
casi nunca tiene en cuenta los servicios
es decir el sector financiero los
seguros los viajes las consultoras
internet claro ya sabemos todos que los
bancos no ganan dinero y que google no
existe verdad pues bien si corregimos
estas dos trampas resulta que eeuu no
tiene ningún agujero comercial por el
nafta sino que incluso obtiene un
superávit que enorme de sus relaciones
con canadá y méxico en concreto 40 mil
millones de dólares cada año
[Música]
vamos que en todo caso los bandoleros
serían los bingos pero vale es verdad el
caso de méxico es un poco diferente
porque aún corrigiendo las trampas y
eeuu sigue registrando cierto déficit
así que la pregunta en este caso que
podemos hacernos es pero cuanto de
grandes este agujero pues agarraros a la
silla porque es de aproximadamente 0 25%
del pib si lo sé no es mucho siento
defraudarte de hecho es un déficit menor
que el que eeuu mantiene por supuesto
con china pero también con japón o
alemania por ejemplo y aquí todavía no
acaba la historia
[Música]
la industria automotriz a pesar de lo
que se cuenta amigos de visual política
si todas las industrias de eeuu exportan
más a méxico de lo que importan salvo la
de los automóviles pero claro es que las
compañías que más coches hechos en
méxico venden a los eeuu son
precisamente las de origen
estadounidense como por ejemplo por
general motors así que ya os podéis
imaginar dónde van a parar los
beneficios generados verdad
e
si así es lo habéis clavado los
beneficios regresan a eeuu tanto en
forma de coches más baratos como de
beneficios listos para ser distribuidos
entre los millones de accionistas de
estas compañías pero todavía hay más se
suele decir que la razón principal para
que las empresas lleven sus fábricas a
mexico son los salarios más bajos bueno
esto es verdad pero sólo un abrazo a
medias porque no es la razón principal
no no no
no lo que más le interesa a las
compañías de coches a ford general
motors insisto es que al día de hoy
méxico tiene muchos más tratados de
libre comercio que eeuu lo que les
permite producir fabricar en este país y
vender en mercados como brasil o la
unión europea ahorrándose un montón de
dinero en aranceles concretamente más de
700 millones de dólares cada año no está
mal verdad brasil ama los autos hechos
en mexico y dónde va a parar el
beneficio de todas estas operaciones lo
habéis vuelto a adivinar a eeuu como en
los casinos parece que aquí la casa
siempre gana
gracias a méxico las compañías
automovilísticas de eeuu son más
competitivas y tienen más beneficios al
tiempo insisto que los consumidores de
eeuu pueden comprar sus coches
muchísimos más baratos
llegados a este punto una buena pregunta
sería pero que hacen los yankees con
tantos beneficios pues como decía
bastiat van a parar a lo que no se ve
con más dinero en el bolsillo los
ciudadanos de eeuu compran más ropa van
más al cine o cambian más de smartphones
insumen sigue las ruletas continúa
girando tal vez por ello las cifras de
empleo en eeuu estén en récord
históricos
según las investigaciones realizadas
acabar con la relación comercial entre
eeuu y méxico le supondría a eeuu perder
más de 5 millones de puestos de trabajo
aplicaciones del nafta y eeuu para
méxico sin mexico es importante para
eeuu la inversa es enorme casi el 80% de
las exportaciones mexicanas van a su
vecino del norte así que no es extraño
que la amenaza de trump haya hecho
recordar esa célebre frase que se dice
pronuncio porfirio díaz pobre méxico tan
lejos de dios y tan cerca de eeuu vamos
a ver el tlcan ha sido muy muy positivo
para méxico por ejemplo sabéis quiénes
soy el mayor empleador de este país pues
es wal mart bien sin embargo
desgraciadamente este fenómeno no se ha
visto en el crecimiento de méxico que la
verdad ha sido durante todos estos años
cuando menos anémico así que la pregunta
es qué ha ocurrido bien amigos pues aquí
toca buscar responsabilidades dentro del
país
lo cierto amigos es que los políticos
mexicanos no han sabido aprovechar esta
fabulosa oportunidad para modernizar el
país y hacerlo muy competitivo y eso que
gracias a los altísimos precios del
petróleo en los últimos años han tenido
recursos de sobra para hacerlo
como ya sabéis todos los que seguís
habitualmente a visual político malas
políticas suponen malos resultados
ahora bien quiere decir esto que méxico
se tiene que arrodillar ante donald
trump ni muchísimo menos
cómo se puede defender méxico donald
trump ha amenazado a méxico con imponer
fuertes aranceles a sus productos en
concreto su administración ha hablado de
un 20 por ciento esto de entrada sería
ilegal porque hay una norma de la
organización mundial del comercio que lo
prohíbe en concreto la conocida como
regla de la nación más favorecida que
viene a decir que ningún país miembro de
la oms puede discriminar a ningún otro
de facto esto limitaría el arancel
máximo en caso de tumbarse en nafta al
3% lo que vamos a ver sería un impuesto
a los consumidores y a las empresas
estadounidenses pero prácticamente no
afectaría en absoluto al tráfico
comercial entre los dos países
pero incluso si eeuu con la aprobación
del congreso que es mucho decir quiere
saltarse la legalidad internacional
méxico tiene herramientas más que de
sobra para combatir y tratar de impedir
[Música]
primero pueden poner de su lado toda la
influencia de las grandes
multinacionales que podrían perder miles
de millones de euros que han invertido
en mexico y ojo no hablamos de tres o
cuatro empresarios sino por ejemplo de
todos los trabajadores de estas empresas
y también de sus accionistas de millones
de ahorradores en los eeuu y en segundo
lugar las relaciones entre eeuu y méxico
no son sólo comerciales inmigración
narcotráfico terrorismo y trampa ataca
méxico podría contraatacar por ejemplo
lavándose las manos e inundando eeuu de
drogas y oleadas de inmigrantes de
diferentes países de latinoamérica
lo cierto amigos es que eeuu y méxico se
necesitan mucho más de lo que parece y
desde luego méxico no está en una
posición tan débil como tram se cree
parece que peña nieto aunque es
imprevisible esto sí lo ha entendido y
del gobierno de mexico se dice muy bien
hablemos del nafta renegociamos el
tratado pero también vamos a poner sobre
la mesa el resto de acuerdos bueno tú
qué crees de méxico defenderse con uñas
y dientes incluso a riesgo de
desencadenar una guerra comercial o
acaso debe ser paciente
y dar largas y buscar algún tipo de
conciliación esperamos vuestras
respuestas no os las podéis dejar en los
comentarios y así podemos abrir debate
por supuesto si os ha resultado
interesante este vídeo no olvidéis darle
a like y suscribiros al canal a este y
también a nuestra versión en inglés que
la verdad creo que está quedando de cine
y por si fuese poco también nos podéis
ver todos los domingos en la vanguardia
por cierto si queréis conocer más sobre
las políticas económicas de trabajo y en
particular el gran error que está
cometiendo muy pacífico
no te pierdas este vídeo un saludo y
hasta la próxima amigos
[Música]